don't need to go back to the beginning
do i no because i forgot the microphone
still i have a big voice a
um section e then in our preamble
speaking under rule 20.1 i've not
received any requests
for anyone to speak under rule 21 but
are there any members here
this evening who'd like to do that
no thank you public speaking i've not
received any requests for public
speaking and i can't see any members of
the public who have joined us in the
chamber
so we move on then to
uh
our
declaration our apologies for absence i
have received apologies from councillor
paul moore who is substituted by
councillor maeve saunders welcome thank
you for joining us
um
uh councillor linda piper is uh sends
her apologies
unfortunately it's a health issue
um so she's not able to join us and i
understand that uh councillor tomlinson
uh may be late and councillor boyd may
be joining us a little later
are there any more apologies
yes chair um apologies from councillor
huxley
thank you
the next agenda item then agenda item
number two declarations of interest are
there any declarations that members wish
to make
thank you and then item number three
uh we are asked to approve the minutes
of the overview and scrutiny panel
meeting which was held on the 26th of
october
this year 2021 there is a copy that's
been produced for everybody to
peruse
does anybody have any comments to make
about the minutes
any suggestions for alterations
okay thank you very much can i have a
proposal please
counselor fellows thank you very much
and the seconder please thank you
councillor colin cook
do members agree
thank you very much
agenda item number four then is our
cabinet member
presentation
uh we had a very lively presentation
from the leader at the last meeting
but to be honest and i suspect most of
you would agree with me it was good to
hear so much of what the administration
is planning to do but it lasted from ten
past seven until 20 to nine which was a
shade a shade long uh councillor george
cupp is joining us this evening to talk
to us about community safety and youth
engagement i want to assure you that we
we are not going to pin you to your
chair
for
over an hour and a half i think members
i think members it may be that obviously
questions are are important when we've
seen and heard from uh councillor cup
but i think we perhaps need to try and
tighten it down a bit in terms of the
length of time that we run this
particular agenda item as many questions
can be answered outside of this meeting
um
so i'd like to invite councillor george
cup to come and
give us his presentation which i can see
is going to be up on the screen
thank you very much sharon thank you
everyone for having me this evening um
ideally tonight i just want to run you
through some of the future projects that
we've got going on um especially have a
focus on youth and how we are helping
those that are in need or um just
ensuring that they are safe essentially
um so our first projects are the um the
thanet community safety partnership
projects um and the first one is the ask
angela andrew one so this is quite an
important one at the moment i'm sure
you've seen a lot a lot in the news
about the unfortunate spiking that's
been going on in
nightclubs um especially around
universities this is a
a campaign to ensure that we are helping
um
nightclubs or anything in that that kind
of industry and to ensure that they or
the general public can go up to the bar
and just say the word angela or andrew
and they can get
a cover for their drink
and it's it's a really very important
campaign that as i said is incredibly
vital especially at the moment with all
of the freshers that are going on
and it's something that we have to be
keeping on with our nightlife especially
around ramsgate and uh margate um next
slide please
um so our community shield uh this is a
very interesting um
project
the uh it's very interesting project
which is is a scheme that is being set
up in north down uh road in margate and
westgate where local businesses can sign
up to be
to be a safe place to help those in
immediate need of a place of safety
the community's shield scheme can also
help those who are lost in all in more
extreme situations when they have been
in a victim of a crime or in need of
medical assistance
um and as i said this is this is a
future project um so this will be
hopefully in place by the end of this
financial year
um but it's
something that so the that logo that you
see will be up in um
community shops or places that have
signed up to this scheme so people will
know that they are safe places that they
can go to when they need help um and
it's
i think that kind of nice community feel
where you can ensure that if you um are
unsafe for something along those lines
that you can just look for that sign and
know that you're going to go into some
kind of safety and protection
and the safety web page this is again a
a good kind of um
web page that is going to be set up for
it for
everyone but also a focus on on young
people where it will allow us to
tell people
where
a certain
streets are that have got lights on so
they know that they can be seen
where the taxi ranks are in the offices
very importantly where the ask angela
and ask andrew licence premises are um
and where again where the community
shields safe place locations are so on
those previous um
projects that i've mentioned it's it's a
nice place where it kind of sums
everything up ties everything up so it's
one place where any person can go to
and find where they can get help um just
with a you know a touch of a button on
their smartphone which i think the
majority of people do have now
and the ladder of risk so this is an
initiative where
we go into schools
and
we we talk to them about what they feel
is a risk to them because i think one of
the key things around this is that
what might be risky um or a hazard for
someone that is 13 14 15 is not going to
be the same risk or hazard for someone
that's in their 30s 40s 50s or 80s
so it's incredibly important that we are
ensuring that
they can understand themselves
where
what they would associate with risk and
what level of that ladder they would put
their risk on um and it's it's really
about ensuring that everyone has that
awareness of what they are doing what
risks that may cause
um and
teaching them about how to go about
those risks as well and it's pche which
is physical socials
health and emotional
which are obviously key important um
attributes for anybody growing up so to
ensure that they are understanding those
which all comes into this whole risk uh
ladder
scheme to ensure that they are um
focusing on the the right areas of risk
and
keeping themselves safe
the fanuc bike project a very
interesting one
so this is a
project where
we have been able to
get young people
well an aim to try and get young people
who cause antisocial behavior to get
them to learn about bicycles how they
work give them
i suppose sometimes even a sense of
purpose of of how to do things
understanding mechan
mechanics on on a bike because i think
if you start to understand just the
simple mechanics on a bike then you can
go on and to understand the mechanics of
a car and who knows where that can lead
you you know it can go into the military
to formula one teams anything like that
and it's a real way an initiative to
ensure that the young people that often
maybe feel there isn't
activities to do in thanet it takes them
away from that and gives them something
to do and they are learning something at
the end of it as well
um the bait the bike safety campaign
again this is around bikes and and the
safety of
the
locking them essentially and it's it's
to ensure that people
know
um how to
the the right locks to be put in place
and it's it's a project that will allow
owners to access information about
security and practical help as i said
with locks and uh covers for the like
mic bikes and mopeds
um and it's again because unfortunately
i think those
kinds of thefts are quite a lot targeted
so it's just ensuring that people that
own
those mopeds or bikes know the best way
to secure their property
so operation zigzag
this is a project focused around parking
at schools i'm sure we've all been in a
situation where we've gone up to a
school to pick up
our children or
a relative from school and
the parking is absolutely horrendous out
there and it's not just the parking is
obviously then the issues that that can
face towards traffic um and collisions
um and essentially as well the
importance of the children coming out of
those schools um which is vital because
i think when you've got parked cars very
close to schools children running in
between them your
your visibility of them
drops dramatically and unfortunately
it's it's that
risk that we need to take away and this
is this is a great approach ensuring
that we are working with schools working
with parents
to try and understand where the best
place to park ensuring that those that
are parked in the wrong places can be
moved on um and it's been working
effectively
and it links in very nicely with the
the next slide which is loan a cone
and again this is a a project aimed at
residents who live near schools and have
difficulty getting on and off their
driveway during the busy drop-off and
pick-up times and so this is essentially
us um using information gathered
gathered from operation zigzag
to allow us to give cones to residents
to to put
positioned so that people cannot park in
front of their driveway causing an
obstruction and this allows the
residents to come and go freely from
their property because you know it's
it's
obviously right that somebody living
near school shouldn't be penalized um
because parents are are parking
over their driveways um and again that
is a safety thing because
i'm sure we've all seen it unfortunately
where um tensions get very high when
people are parked in the wrong places
and
it's just ensuring that that risk again
is taken away
the online exploration and exploitation
awareness
so
i'm sure uh this is you know
social media is a very very big factor
in a lot of situations um and our young
people especially
are often uh
indulged in social media and quite often
do not know the side effects of
um what may come from using them
it's even the simple things of there is
a minimum age to use facebook there's a
minimum wage to use whatsapp which isn't
often
um talked about tick tock i'm sure we've
all seen it through
lockdown
tick tock was a massive trend and a
massive hit for people doing dances and
god knows what else i mean unfortunately
i'm afraid to say that i got involved in
it as well um but it was something to do
during lockdown so there we go and it
kept people happy i think that was the
main thing but essentially it's it's so
important that young people know
what is is going on um
for
their safety online and it's that
awareness that we have got to get
through to people
and this is exactly what this this does
so breaking the cycle
um is a
brilliant project that is being
commissioned to engage with young people
in the community to tackle anti-social
behavior or negative behavior uh between
9 pm to 11 p.m the program runs for 14
weeks over five nights per week
um and the it focuses around liaising
with tdc and ken police i'm sharing
information on concerns around locations
showing information and concerns around
behavior sharing information on concerns
around individual behaviors as well
give numbers of engagements and wear
and being directed by the tscp on hot
spot locations and areas of concerns
this is
a
big thing that is will be coming into
place to ensure that
there is a high level engagement that is
tackling the county lines issue um i
don't think it's any secret that there
are issues of county lines in in our
area and this kind of initiative
um is something that
tries to stop that
so the amnesty bins this has been a very
very effective uh campaign
it's a
a bin
that will
this gets put up we have them um located
at most train stations um and in other
hotspot areas i've been identified where
people can go along and
drop their knives or lethal weapons in
and uh i mean i i myself have seen the
the pictures of some of the the weapons
the knives that have come from these
bins and it is absolutely um horrendous
actually that they were even on the
streets but what is a positive is that
people have been engaging with them and
been dropping a lot of um offensive
weapons in there
and is it's
allowing
a reduction of um these
horrible weapons on our streets
and we can take them away efficiently
and put them obviously in in a safe
place where they're off the streets
so the the safer streets
we received 378 000 pounds from the home
office which is
also supported by the police and crime
commissioner which is sorry funded by
the police and crime commissioner um and
the aim with this is to reduce the crime
in east cliff and central harbour wards
in thanat
and it's also going to be funded for cct
cctv cameras graffiti removal machines
community sheds
strengthening families strengthening
communities course for parents planters
personal security home security
improvement
moped theft prevention and protection
street lighting alleyway gating and
waste management
and of course the information
implementation lists will be by at the
end of the financial year um but we this
these projects or this project will be
sustained over the coming years as well
so youtube uh we are
on the process of creating content for
our youtube channel to help explain what
we do
at
what we do to members of the public
we have lots of projects happening
throughout the year and a constant
message from the community is that they
do not know what we do
we want to use this platform to
demonstrate what we do and how we do it
and why youtube is a is a great platform
to get messages out there especially to
engage with younger people
quite often i think younger people don't
know what is going on in the community
and
they
as i said earlier they are very much
involved with social media
so why not
target them where where they will be
looking and youtube is a great platform
to to do that with um and hopefully by
doing this we will get more engagement
with with
future projects and the projects that we
will be running
so tdc projects
so the
winter half which is a tdc active than
it shall continue to support the
delivery of the half program during
christmas holiday to ensure as many
children families are reached
this involves continued work with local
schools and activity providers aiming to
provide positive experience for young
people and lasting memories and that's
not to mention this is obviously a
future project we did also have the um
summer half
which was incredibly um
engaging and
brought a lot of positivity to a lot of
families and a lot of young people
the dwp partnership grant for the yes
project so they're working with
partnership with dwp to support young
people aged between 18 to 24 back into
employment um we saw a very big rise of
unemployment of young people um
especially in the thana area when we
came out of lockdown because obviously
all the hospitalities and areas like
that closed down
and um
this
it is vital i think that we
help back and and publish these kind of
projects to help young people into
employment um and
it allows us to work with the young
people and that have been identified by
uh work coaches that are experiencing
low confidence and self-esteem poor
mental well-being and little motivation
um which was a big side effect from uh
the uh
lockdowns because there wasn't that
engagement with people they weren't
getting used to having interviews
and sometimes unfortunately when people
did have interviews they weren't hearing
back from people um and that created
um a side effect of people
thinking that well i'm not good enough
to to be employed and this this yes
project is
um
making sure that people understand that
they are worthy to get a job and they
should get employed
so our future projects are a doorstep
sports programme
the thanet youth employee employability
hub
this girl's can fanuc campaign the
thanit summer in olympics 2024 which is
something incredibly exciting obviously
when we've got the 2024 uh olympics we
were are doing something incredibly
exciting in than it ourselves around
that the uh paddle boarding for
ex-offenders and
my own uh little baby the youth cabinet
advisory group which is um
something that is being worked on
by penny and a team and it's it's
progressing very very nicely um and
obviously the goal right now is just to
set up a youth advisory group where they
can come along
talk to the cabinet advise us on any
projects or policies that they would
like to be involved in
and help us make decisions
around
their future around the district
and
i think that this is a great stepping
stone
into eventually getting a youth council
but the most important thing around this
is to
ensure that we walk
before we run in this
that's
that's everything yeah
if anyone has any questions please feel
free to ask
thank you very much george for a very uh
interesting
report i i guess it's uh
this question almost asks itself but are
you intending to make these slides
available to all councillors
uh
quite apart from the councillors who are
on this committee is that your intention
please yeah absolutely um i think that
people are especially members should
should know about the projects that are
going on so very happy to make these uh
be shared with all members
thank you and just as a
a follow-up to that there are lots of us
of course who are
twin hatters but there are a number of
town councillors uh who are not and uh
margate chelsea trustees
well i think they're all twin tatters
aren't they yes they are but could we
have some copies for for example
ramsgate town council so that
councillors
at ramsgate even if it's one copy that
the council at ramsgate then reproduces
if members
want to have a look at them i think that
would be quite helpful too
just perhaps one to each council and let
the council
reproduce them
thank you
members uh it's a very interesting
presentation thank you yes let's have
our
first question and then councillor
austin after that
okay thank you and yes that was a great
presentation and some really great stuff
for young people in there um
what i'd like to know a bit more about
is you highlighted the thing about young
people not knowing what was going on and
so how are you going to advertise
all the sorts of things you were talking
about in your presentation to young
people particularly those difficult to
reach ones those that might be out of
school or looked after children or those
most vulnerable ones
and just as a small one for the safest
streets with the boards east cliff and
central harbour how were they identified
for that funding
as opposed to other areas
thank you
so the engagement round around these
projects is absolutely your you're right
it it's it's so important that we
are
reaching out to as many young people as
possible from all different kinds of
backgrounds um
the the youtube side of things is is one
of the ways that we can do that um we
are
looking at the the social media aspects
of of
our approach so the um safer
neighborhood meetings that are currently
going on um i was just in a meeting the
other day with the
district commander
and the chief executive leader and we
were saying how we need to ensure that
these are being engaged again by young
people so
that is again we need we are looking at
a different uh approach around that
whether it is more social media based
whether we need to be doing leaflet
dropping um whether we are seeing or not
if we can do posters around everywhere
whether we're going into youth club
schools and which is process that we are
doing as well we are going to schools
now we are um ensuring that we are
having those conversations that so young
people are aware of these projects um
and then your second question i will
pass over to penny
thank you i did quickly write it out and
so they were identified through the
police and crime commissioner um from
the commissioner's office and we were
invited we were one of four councils in
kent that were invited to apply so it
was based on the inquisitive crime data
so we didn't have an option we were just
told if you want to apply it's for these
two awards um and that's what we did we
have previously applied for
other
funding through the same streams but
weren't successful but they were for
other awards in the in the district
because that was related to different
types of crime so yeah we don't get a
choice unfortunately
thank you chair uh that was really
impressive and and i for one had
absolutely no idea of the range of
projects that are involved and i'm
somebody who before being on the council
has been very involved in my local
community so it's definitely um you know
a well-kept secret that shouldn't be and
we should be out there promoting some of
these great projects uh just a couple of
things i wanted to ask the first one was
about the the bike the bike maintenance
bit which is something i know in
ramsgate time town team we've tried to
set up in the past and i'm really
pleased to see that that's gone ahead i
want to know where it's actually
happening at the moment and whether
there are plans to expand that
and then the second thing i wanted to
ask was
about the um safer streets funding
because it's it's uh um central hub
awards so that's we had some really
useful information originally from joe
taylor about that uh when it when it was
first approved but we don't seem to have
had any updates since so i'm wondering
if we can have something through to ward
councillors to give us a bit of uh
information about what's happening at
the moment and most particularly how we
can help
and the third thing i wanted to say was
as a governor of newington school i'm so
pleased to see that you're going to be
there doing the parking because there is
parking as far away from from as i am
from the chair and people aren't using
it they're parking on the zigzags
instead so thank you
thank you councillor austin um so the
the bike project currently um isn't live
but it will be soon the locations i'll
be honest i don't know but i will find
out for you um and i will let you know
uh the question regarding the funding
the safe safe streets uh again in
discussions uh that i had with the chief
executive leader i think we are planning
potentially doing a members briefing on
it so a full um understanding could be
known from all members
so you're clear on what is going on and
i can only say that i'm pleased you're
happy about the parking
thank you members councillor curry
thank you chair um thanks for the
presentation george really interesting
lots of really good projects there i
think we're really helpful it was good
to see the um the community shield
program
that will be planned for north dam road
and i was just wondering how best it
would be to get the message out to local
businesses
could we do a maybe a leaflet drop
and i think that would be really
effective thanks
so absolutely yeah we definitely will be
doing leaflet drops and also we are
visiting the the businesses around the
area um because it's it's important
there is that engagement with them and
we get as many businesses on board with
this initiative um so yeah we will do
everything we can to ensure we've got as
many businesses on board with this
of course i'm sorry i remembered
something else i was going to ask which
was about the community shield which is
i've read something just recently about
thorley taverns um being involved in
some kind of a safety community safety
thing is this are they part of the
community shield or is it something
different
that's asked angela and ask andrew
can i come in sorry
thorly taverns do get involved with a
number of our um
late-night type of project so yeah but
specifically at the moment it's that one
thank you very much and as it happens i
was reading various posts on social
media today about ask angela i haven't
seen about the andrew i was completely
unaware
of the ask andrew facility but there's
quite a few posts today on social media
about uh
angela so thank you very much for that
i'd like to thank you
george council cup for coming to the
meeting this evening and sharing with us
members thank you for your questions and
we will look forward to receiving copies
of the slides in due course
before we move on to a gender item five
could i you do not have to say i realize
you are very very busy people so thank
you very much
uh for coming this evening and i'll just
give you a moment or two if you want to
slip out
[Music]
number five then members uh welcome
kerry it's
glad you're able to join us
um agenda item number five then is the
housing performance report um and i'd
like to invite uh mr bob porter to
present it to us thank you
thank you chair
um
actually uh sally o'sullivan who's our
tenant and leaseholder services manager
uh we'll run through um some
introductions to the report
and then obviously myself sally and
councillor bayfielder here
if members have any questions
after the introduction that you want to
ask obviously we'll do our best to
answer them um so i'll pass over to
sally
thank you
um so
it's been in in the year since
transition the team has come a long way
and we feel we're making real difference
in the service that we offer
our performance continues to improve of
areas of landlord compliance where a
recent audit gave us reasonable
assurance
income management and at keeping up with
our capital works programme
for example we've completed all of the
surveys now on the tower blocks and
we're starting to scope the works that
we will be carrying out there and this
will include the replacement of the
external wall system replacing windows
and upgrading the heating systems
by the end of december we have the
specification ready to tender for the
works at royal crescent
and we're halfway through a program to
refurbish the lifts across our blocks as
well
anecdotally our customers have told us
that the service has improved in a
recent consultation which was to find
out what we need to do to build better
relationship with our customers
positive comments we received included
you provide a good service and i feel i
already have a good professional
relationship with you as my landlord
services got better since it's been back
with tdc before i couldn't get through
but now phil you keep us informed and
providing value for money
amazing at what you're doing i've never
had any problems with tdc i did with the
ekh so glad they've gone
we know what areas we need to improve on
and we're applying focus the landlord
compliance to complete fire risk
assessment actions and the electrical
safety certificates so that we're in a
position to request the regulator remove
our notice
our void performance is not where we
want it to be and therefore a recent
restructure with the purpose of ensuring
we have human resource in the right
place has created a void team to focus
on reducing our void turnaround time and
has put more resource to the front line
to improve the condition of our estates
the other area we need to address is the
performance of our day-to-day repairs
through mirs
we are feeling very positive about
relationship with mirs at this time as
they've just dedicated to us our own
contract manager and team
we have a service improvement plan in
place with them with which they are
positively engaging
so if anyone has any questions
thank you very much
for that
members we have a a number of
issues we've been asked to have a look
at and comment on
um
so i'd like to invite you to do that now
i think it
probably goes without saying but uh
you know me i'm gonna say it anyway
um
the council clearly
started from quite a bad position if
that were not the case
there would have been no need to bring
the service back in house i think that's
a reasonably fair comment to make so
your comments particularly around
paragraph two
2.1 we're very proud of what we've
accomplished over the past year
shows that you know you have been
working very very hard and 2.3 we have
in place an 18-month service improvement
plan
i remember i was i was reading this i
was thinking well
you've started from a bad place
the old phrase that rome wasn't built in
a day
applies here there's a lot to be done
and clearly the team i'm working very
hard at trying to
deal with those issues notably the uh
servicing and repairs i was looking at
the
annex and seeing the level of repairs
that are carried out on time and
and so on so thank you very much for
that members do we have
uh any questions you'd like to ask or
comments you'd like to make
on the report
yes please counselor king
thank you and uh thank you for the
report i'm particularly interested in
the mayor's contract i'm really glad to
hear that they're engaging well
with the improvement program
but i'd like to know what are the
penalties for them if they don't meet
the targets and how long is the contract
with them i mean if they continue to
underperform when will the contract be
reviewed thank you
jeff would you like us to answer those
questions yes
yeah um on the first thing though there
aren't any specific penalty
um like financial penalties within the
current contract arrangements with
mirrors um obviously our focus is on
making sure that they do fulfill the
performance targets that were within the
contract um and those performance
targets are the ones that we report on
so you can see
where where they're
how they're doing um obviously if we
have where we're aware of any service
failures we take those up directly with
the contract management style fatmirs
and we have regular liaison meetings
with them with our tenant
representatives as part of that as well
um so we have an operational meeting
monthly with the manner quarterly
strategic level meeting with
representatives from the tenant body
um
when's the contract up well 2025
um so it sounds a fair way away but it
isn't really um and over the course of
the next year we'll need to start
thinking about what we want to put in
place after that
thank you very much council austin
um i want to ask about it as well if i
may i mean it's encouraging to see that
that a number of the indicators um the
performance has improved but i was
worried about the
days to complete non-urgent works which
seems to be way off target and i'm just
wondering what other factors might be
involved in that is that
is that to do with mir's performance or
are there other things coming in there
um
that that are affecting that
thanks
thank you
um so
the so there's been a couple of things
that have affected the days to complete
urgent works um
there have been they've mirrored
themselves had difficulty employing
contractors to the trades
we've also had materials issues with
getting materials following brexit
following pandemic
because of that we've got a massive
backlog of jobs and that has compounded
the statistics
so in a nutshell that is that is why
it's so poor performance there um they
have rectified that now we have the
trades in place and we're getting hold
of materials but because of the backlog
it's taking longer to resolve
okay great thank you
council curry
yeah could you tell me um where the
monthly tenant and leasehold meetings
are held so we can pass this on to
residents
thank you
thank you
currently the meetings are held online
we haven't managed to get together yet
but we are looking to be able to get
together
we'll be at the council offices when we
are able to
thank you chair um
firstly i just want to clarify typo
um which is on page
31
where it goes it does not reflect now we
listen to their views and act upon them
so i presume that's meant to be how we
listen to their views and not i presume
we have been listening to people's views
for time
and the second thing um was
could you talk a bit more about um
in lit on the next page about the number
of training opportunities offered to
residents
um
i know it's like zero i'm going to
presume it's because it hasn't started
but i'd like quite to know what your
plans are
for that in terms of training and
engagement with with the residents
so the intention is to offer training to
our engaged residents um and that would
be to help them
um scrutinize so training to enable them
to scrutinize our performance
but also
other training we want them we want
residents to help us with um equality
impact assessments on things like
policies and
[Music]
when we're doing procurement for
contracts so we want to offer training
for that and also training for so that
they can assist us with procurement as
well
coach again
thank you
the properties that are returned in a
poor state of repair um
probably need to be here um
i presume there's a schedule when there
are visits to the properties in the
meantime
so i just wanted to know or understand a
bit more about that are we flagging up
properties
along the way or are we only finding out
about these properties at the end of the
tenancy and is there anything we can do
to address this in future
thank you
thank you
so
we are to be able to address that we are
starting a programme of tenancy visits
to visit 10 of tenancies that we don't
hear from
year to year to identify issues with
property but also to identify
issues where residents may require more
support from us as well
we hope that this will help
with with identifying properties ahead
of time so that we can help people live
in better condition before the end of
the tenancy
um
as well um where um
where existing tenants have asked to
move through a transfer which is the
source of some of our empty properties
um we also do
an inspection prior to agreeing that
move so if there are any issues with the
condition of the property at that point
then we would raise them with the tenant
prior to approving it
and so that picks up some
um it's worth also saying the tenancy
audit program um as well as helping with
with um
issues about condition can also pick up
any issues with tenancy fraud so that
was part of the rationale for
introducing that was to help us
tackle
tenancy forward identify and tackle
tenancy fraud
question if i may obviously it is
disappointing as council king says to to
read that so many properties came back
in a very poor state but that links into
the other other bit which you're
starting from
a bad position i think it's
reasonable to assume that most
issues of damp and mold are going to
occur between
october and april uh most complaints
coming forward are going to come in that
sort of time
and a lot of them it seems to me are
probably not damp and mold but
poor ventilation where tenants don't
open the windows and you get dust
settling on the joints and that goes
black and they think it's moldy and it's
not
so is
during the course of the winter months
i'm not talking about extra visits but
in routine visits or planned maintenance
visits that you're making to properties
are we going to be doing something to
i don't mean to sound arrogant here but
to educate tenants about the difference
between
damp and mold and
dust and condensation we're going to
take the opportunities as they come in
other words
thank you counselor piper um well yes i
think it's a straight answer to that um
dampen mould is um yeah an issue that we
come across
often in relation to condensation and
the way that you're quite right in the
way in the question you've asked you
know um condensation quite often could
be linked to
um the way the heating's used whether
the properties ventilated um and so on
and um so yeah our officers do um
provide advice about that and we've also
run um we've run articles in our um
resident newsletters about managing
managing moisture in in the home to try
and reduce
issues of condensation
um it is an issue that comes up
frequently so you know it's a thing
we'll continue to
to work on um
yeah yes and there is some information
on our not yet we're not yet we're going
to be putting some information on our
web pages about it as well
thank you thank you very much members
are there any more
questions for the team
okay remember
for quarter
one
uh taking note of annexes one two three
and four and note
the contents of the reports for quarter
two annexes five six
seven
and eight
can i have a proposal please
counselor fellows and a seconder
councillor curry do members agree
thank you very much
agenda item number six then is the
increased provision of housing response
officers at the tower blocks
it's
officially on one of the supplementary
agenda sections but i'm sure
members have had an opportunity to
see it uh mr porter please
well it's the same routine actually it's
gonna be sally introducing the report
thank you
thank you
um so uh one of the areas our customers
tells us we need to improve is in the
condition of our estates this includes
communal cleaning litter rubbish removal
presence of weeds and our paved areas
and fly tipping
to improve performance in these areas we
need further resource and we consider
increasing the number of hros we have
working in the field to give us will
give us the resources we need
we felt the provision of hros dedicated
to the tower blocks to be the right
decision over outsourcing so for example
increasing the scope of our cleaning
contract or the grounds maintenance
contract
because of the nature of high-wise
living means more residents in a smaller
area requiring more frequent cleaning of
communication of communal areas we
experience increased incidence of asb
also therefore by providing dedicated
hros to tower blocks will mean
increasing our presence on the estates
the hros will become a familiar face to
our tenants and leaseholders providing a
tdc officer to report matters to making
residents feel safer as an increased
presence brings with it increased
security and assurance against asb
we have direct control over the quality
of work and flexibilities over the
priorities that they have
as there is not enough budget to provide
two extra hoas for the tower blocks we
asked our tenants and leaseholders in a
recent consultation if they would
contribute to the cost of these officers
by paying for them as part of their
service charge
as you can see from the report a
majority of attendance and leaseholders
that responded to the conf content
sorry the consultation said that they
agreed to this suggestion
in addition tenants and leaseholders who
said that they said that they knew what
the hros did were more likely to support
making a contribution to the cost of the
additional offices
if there are any questions
thank you very much members
any questions thank you then
our
task receiving their members is uh to
make comments if we have them
um
and
it will go from here to cabinet who will
be asked to approve the introduction of
the service charge for the tenants and
leaseholders of the six tower blocks in
the district
um and to recommend to full council the
necessary budget is approved for this
service so i think from here it goes to
cabinet for
their decision
uh members can i have a proposal please
count to the fellows second to please
council ratigan
do members agree
thank you very much
[Applause]
likewise if the team
i know you were very busy you're welcome
to stay but if you'd like to leave
that's uh
fine too
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much members agenda item
number seven then is uh the item
concerning proposed fees and charges
um
mr blundell i think you're going to
present it to us this evening unless
you've got someone hiding that you're
going to pass it on to that we can't see
thank you chair good evening members
members will be aware that this is um
the report that went to cabinets
on thursday last week that is now
presented to osp for your consideration
uh prior to that it was uh fees and
charge setting process was considered by
a cabinet advisory group that met on two
occasions in
september and october and a number of
recommendations that made by the cabinet
advisor group that have been reflected
in the fees and charges schedule that
are presented they include an increase
in the collection of garden waste to 55
pounds it currently is 53
pounds that's a two pound increase
compared to the current year
also the consideration of the
establishment of a pilot scheme for
to examine the benefits of
reduced parking charges for low emission
vehicles
and
also for the finance team to revisit the
charges for
the crematorium
in addition to that at cabinets on
thursday
it was a proof that the fees and charges
will be revisited to increase them by a
three percent increase as opposed to the
two percent increase that you'll see uh
presented in the schedule of fees and
charges that work is still ongoing by my
team at the moment um so subsequent to
that work there will be some amendments
to the figures that are presented in the
schedule that you have in front of you
and that will go to council for full
decision on the
9th of december
happy to take any questions on the
substance of the fees and charges that
are presented to you or the process that
we've been through in order to arrive at
the position that we're at now
members any questions comments
from mr bundle
i must admit i didn't uh
spot the misprint
until it was too late the printed copy
i've got in front of us increases bulky
waste to 55 pounds but that's obviously
a typo that was it's garden waste
bulky waste uh is going up i understand
four pounds to twenty six uh two to
thirty correct thirty pounds um
personally and i forgive me members i
know it's an area of the
the life around planet that i am
personally involved in but the the um
the use of the crematorium for members
it still
concerns me that we are
amongst the poorest in kent and yet
somehow we charge a great deal more than
other areas for
cremations and burials and the use of
our
facilities and
there is a
there are a lot of new charges that have
become necessary because
of uh live streaming facilities and
putting up onto the main screen moving
photographs with or without music and so
on there are a lot of additional charges
if i could put in a plea for those of us
who conduct services at the crematorium
there is an overrun charge which is
automatically applied
to
families um and
if for example i'm conducting a service
at 12 o'clock and the one before me over
runs by 15 minutes the family i'm
looking after get
charged and then if i'm late everybody
else does all the way along the line so
i i know it's necessary uh but it does
seem to me to be um
quite quite a high charge compared to
other places
i go to
and
just as a um probably not really my role
here as the chair but there are a couple
of new private crematoria being built
fairly locally
and it may well be that
if their charges for the use of their
facilities are considerably lower
and with the
increasing popularity of non-attend
services or
pure cremation as i've no doubt you've
seen on the television
people may well move to have their loved
ones cremated elsewhere and the ashes
brought back into the reason so i
just as a word of caution and please
forgive me but i think we need to be
careful that we don't
actually uh
inc increase our fees
too much though i do note of course this
year it is only a ten pound increase
so it's not a massive increase but
perhaps the other additional charges
um
enable these things that the
bills build up very very quickly
um thank you very very much uh for
the report we are uh are there
any recommendations we wish to make or
we're going to leave this now with
cabinets to uh it's coming to council on
the
9th
of december can i have a proposal please
council fellows and the seconder
council ratican thank you very much the
members agree
thank you
the next agenda item is agenda item
number number eight
thank you very much
um a review of the work program for
21 22.
most of us are familiar of course with
the contents
of this work program that we've been
putting together
um does anyone have any comments
that they'd like to make
to the program as we have it uh perhaps
council fellows were there any words you
wanted to
offer regarding the coastal waste review
working group that's fine yeah we've we
had i've had a couple of really good
meetings since the last time we met here
one with paris and town councils
which went quite well um and we had
really good one in the in the chamber
here last week with about um
15 15 members of volunteer
litter pickers who came along and gave
their views and yeah really good really
good recommendations from them which we
will all put together and present
our future meeting yeah good it's been
good and very interesting the people
that are my commit party grade's been
very interested here
thank you very much and thank you for
the work that you are doing members if
there's no more comments we're asked to
note
uh the report
agenda item nine then
um
we are also asked to note the report for
the forward plan exempt cabinet report
list
members have any comments they wish to
make
about that list i think much of it is
fairly well known
to most of us
already
okay members may ask you then to note
that report also
and that
then brings us to the end of business
for this evening so we'll conclude the
meeting closed at 8 00 pm and the live
stream of this meeting will now end
thank you very much